[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight joe biden went on
television today this afternoon and
talked to the country about afghanistan
he said among other things that we had
no choice but to leave and on that
question he is right the united states
should have left afghanistan 19 years
ago when it became obvious that osama
bin laden wasn't there and had fled to
pakistan was no reason to stay in the
country and the longer we remained the
worse it was always going to be
the question is and the relevant
question today is how exactly do you get
out
just because something is necessary
doesn't mean you get to ignore the
details of it if you learned you needed
an emergency appendectomy would it
matter to you who performed the
operation a surgeon with a scalpel or a
drunk guy with a pocket knife yes it
would matter to you
but it didn't matter to joe biden
apparently he barely mentioned the
withdrawal today biden did the necessary
thing in the ugliest possible way
if you've been watching television
during the day you've probably seen this
footage it's terrified men in sandals
clinging to the side of a c-17 as it
attempts to leave afghanistan
and this is the iconic photo of the
moment it's the final humiliating scene
of the american occupation of
afghanistan that means that after 20
years and trillions of dollars our
leaders couldn't manage to pull off an
orderly retreat they couldn't even
secure a single runway
and that's the main lesson of the fall
of kabul we are led by buffoons they
have no idea what they're doing we know
that now they're imposters everything
they touch turns to chaos not just there
but here these are the people who run
the amtrak station in midtown manhattan
the one that's filled with drug addicts
they're the people in charge of the
power grid in the state of california
they have no useful skills and yet
somehow these same people assured us
they were going to turn stone age
afghanistan into modern belgium
remembering it now is bitter and
hilarious
at this point our leaders are so
discredited they're running out of ways
to criticize the taliban
is the bide administration really going
to attack the new government of
afghanistan for forcing women to cover
their faces
are american diplomats actually going to
lecture taliban leaders about toppling
statues probably not going to happen
that's how much credibility our leaders
have lost how much moral authority they
have squandered in the past 20 years
but most of what they've lost is their
self-awareness they have none
until just this weekend for example they
had no idea how badly they were failing
in afghanistan
here's john kirby the pentagon
explaining that calm down america
everything in kabul is under control
keep in mind we have not edited this
tape and it's not from last year this is
three days ago
kabul is not
uh right now
um
in an imminent threat environment
oh good job john kirby think he'll keep
his job of course he'll keep his job a
man who's willing to defend pregnant
fighter pilots can work in washington
forever and so can mark million at the
joint chiefs and the rest of the woke
clowns at the pentagon generals who are
much more worried about white rage in
west virginia than they are about our
enemies abroad what was the last time
these guys want a war seriously they
hate it when you ask that question
nothing bothers them more but what's the
answer when was that
and while we're at it how about the
intel agencies their job is very
specific
give policymakers some rough sense of
what's going to happen in the world
especially on the big questions so they
can make wise decisions how's the intel
world doing on that
let's see the collapse of the soviet
union 911 the fall of kabul not small
things major history changing events
they missed all of those completely they
had no idea
so why are they still there well because
someone's got to read your text messages
got to make sure you're not making fun
of trans people or anything like that
and then there's the biden
administration overseeing all of it the
group led by the senior credit card
shill from delaware and staffed by
power-hungry non-entities who believe
their god
hubris that doesn't describe the vibe at
the current white house it's much more
grandiose than that and there's far less
justification for it
here's our sitting national security
advisor for example he is 44 years old
as far as we can tell he has never had
an actual job
outside of school he has no
accomplishments whatsoever
watch this highly respected road scholar
explained that in fact everything you're
seeing on tv from afghanistan is a
victory
how do you explain getting this so wrong
well first savannah to be fair
the helicopter has been the mode of
transport from our embassy to the
airport for the last 20 years but you
know the launch
mechanism
no no it's the last minute scramble you
know that it's the last minute scramble
when the assurances from the president
himself were this was not what we were
going to see the reason that there are
u.s forces at the airport effectuating a
successful draw down of our embassy
securing the airport to be able to get
other people out is because the
president pre-positioned those forces
thousands of them in the gulf so they
could be moved in rapidly in the event
that there was a rapid collapse
oh
so they're effectuating a successful
drawdown of our embassy so that's what
we call it when you burn your files and
fleeing a helicopter from approaching
gunfire you're just effectuating another
successful drawdown woohoo
we could go on we could torture you with
the failures and the details we haven't
even mentioned our quote secretary of
state tony blinken a man so mediocre you
gasp when you hear him speak can you
really be that dumb and run the
department of state yeah you can
and the last several decades of american
foreign policy prove that you can
america is
afghanistan is not the first country our
leaders have left worse than they found
it the list of those countries is long
and sadly it's growing
part of the reason is that for decades
left-wing academics in the u.s have used
the developing world as a laboratory to
test their theories about how societies
ought to be ordered but aren't
over time they've constructed a parallel
government of ngos that work alongside
our pentagon and our state department as
well as with the united nations to
impose radical social engineering
projects on the world's poorest people
who have no say in the matter
over the past 20 years for example
congress has allocated close to a
billion dollars to export academic
feminism to afghanistan where that money
go well it went to programs like a two
years master's degree
in gender and women's studies offered at
kabul university something afghans
apparently never knew they needed
another us government effort meanwhile
funded quote activities that educate and
engage afghan men and boys to challenge
gender stereotypes right they weren't
doing that enough
and of course always and everywhere our
leaders enforced the most american of
all cultural exports affirmative action
american-funded gender advisors demanded
that women compromise at least 10
percent of the afghan national army and
a still larger proportion of that
country's political leadership
thanks to american imposed gender quotas
dozens of women ultimately were
installed as representatives in afghan's
parliament how'd that work well the
whole thing was a sham as always in fact
many of these new female legislators had
never been to the provinces they claimed
to represent
almost nobody in afghanistan liked any
of this by the way and why would they as
one usaid official conceded in a
classified report quote focusing on
gender made things more unstable because
it caused revolts
it caused revolts
but officials kept doing it they kept
pushing radical gender politics anyway
because they could because they were in
charge of these stone age people they
were going to educate
this is the face of the late american
empire gender studies seminars at
gunpoint this is not like other empires
unlike other empires ours does not
operate for our benefit america toppled
saddam but took no oil remember that
instead the entire point of our imperial
project is to give meaning to the empty
lives of the neo-liberal bureaucrats who
administer it and then enrich the
contractors who work for them who are in
risk you'll be happy to know
what role do the rest of us play in this
none we just pay for it
yesterday to underscore that point that
by administration told us that american
citizens would not be given priority in
the evacuation from kabul
so our government's official position is
that american lives are not more
valuable than the lives of foreigners
but you already knew that because you've
seen our southern border
the people who made the afghan
occupation possible would like to see a
lot more of our southern border much
more unrestrained immigration to the us
bring in the refugees they're screaming
tonight that's the only lesson they're
taking from this debacle
america must not stand idly by mitt
romney tweeted today the president must
urgently rush to defend rescue and give
and expand asylum there is no time to
spare
there's lots of time to spare as
americans die of fentanyl ods and
millions of foreign nationals whose
identities we can't confirm move here
but when it comes to bringing afghans to
our country there's no time to spare and
liz cheney firmly agrees with that so
does her friend bill crystal and nancy
pelosi and victoria nuland at the state
department and so many more so many more
just like them
these are the architects of the disaster
we are watching unfold on television
they should be groveling for our
forgiveness but they're not why because
contrition requires decency there's no
chance
so we're getting it and if history is
any guide and it's always a guide we
will see many refugees from afghanistan
resettle in our country in coming months
probably in your neighborhood
and over the next decade that number may
swell to the millions
so first we invade and then we're
invaded it is always the same
we'll be spending a lot more time on
that subject in recent in coming weeks
because it matters
but first since kabul has just fallen it
might be worth asking the most obvious
question of all
why did the taliban win
how did the 6th century triumph over the
21st century
there are indications that the single
most notorious and reviled government in
the world primitive people famous for
their brutality rigidity and
humorlessness
are more popular in parts of afghanistan
than they were when we expelled the
molas from kandahar 20 years ago they
don't seem to be less popular
so how did that happen what's the answer
we had opposed to think about that let's
not just blow past it like it was an act
of god it's not what is the answer
well countries are very complicated all
of them so they're likely many answers
but one of those answers may be that the
population of afghanistan has firmly
rejected what our leaders were selling
it over 20 years
it turns out that the people of
afghanistan don't actually want gender
studies symposia
they didn't actually buy the idea that
men can become pregnant they thought
that was ridiculous they don't hate
their own masculinity they don't think
it's toxic they like the patriarchy some
of their women like it too
so now they're getting it all back
so maybe it's possible that we failed in
afghanistan because the entire
neoliberal program is grotesque it's a
joke it's contrary to human nature it
answers none of our deepest human
desires it is merely a performance
staged
for the performer it's not even supposed
to improve your life
it's ridiculous and ideas that
ridiculous can only be imposed by force
only with armed men at gunpoint the
moment these ideas are not mandatory the
second the troops withdraw in fact
people tend to revert to the lives that
they prefer to live
that may be the real lesson of
afghanistan let's hope our leaders
notice hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else